>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
USUALLY BY THIS POINT IN A
PRESIDENTIAL CYCLE, WE’VE GOT A
PRETTY GOOD IDEA OF WHAT THE
CANDIDATES BELIEVE AND YOU THINK
I’LL BE ESPECIALLY TRUE THIS
YEAR, JOE BIDEN HAS BEEN IN
POLITICS FOR MORE THAN HALF A
CENTURY.
THIS IS HIS THIRD RUN FOR
PRESIDENT.
SINCE 1969, THE YEAR OF THE MOON
LANDING, JOE BIDEN HAS BEEN
YAMMERING IN PUBLIC VIRTUALLY
WITHOUT STOPPING.
UNTIL THIS YEAR.
THIS YEAR, THE FAMOUSLY CHATTY
JOE BIDEN HAS HAD ALMOST
NOTHING.
HIS ADVISORS CLAIM THAT’S
BECAUSE OF COVID-19 BUT NOBODY
BELIEVES THAT.
EVERYBODY KNOWS WHY BIDEN WON’T
APPEAR IN PUBLIC.
WHEN HE DOES EMERGE, THINGS TEND
TO GET STRAINED.
BIDEN’S WORDS TAKE ON A KIND OF
PSYCHEDELIC QUALITY, THE
SENTENCES THAT SEEM TO BE
CONNECTED YET AT THE SAME TIME
THEY ARE STRANGE AND DISJOINTED.
NEWSPAPER TAXIS APPEAR ON THE
SHORE, ROCKING HORSE PEOPLE EAT
MARSHMALLOW PIE, IT’S
MESMERIZING TO WATCH, YOU CAN
ALMOST MAKE OUT THE TANGERINE
TREES AND THE MARMALADE SKY.
>> WE SAW IT IN OUR
ADMINISTRATION, LOWER THE TAXES,
TO 28%.
LOWER TO 21.
I’M GOING TO RAISE IT BACK UP TO
28.
NOT SUFFICIENT TO BUILD BACK, WE
HAVE TO BUILD BACK BETTER.
THAT’S WHAT MY PLAN IS, TO BUILD
BACK BETTER.
>> THESE ON SOMEBODY ELSE’S
CHILDREN, THEIR ALL OUR
CHILDREN, THE CHILDREN, THOSE
CHILDREN ARE THE KITE STRINGS
THAT HOLD OUR NATIONAL
AMBITIONS.
THE ONLY ENTITY, THE ONLY THING
THAT CAN TEAR AMERICA APART IS
AMERICA ITSELF PERIOD.
>> Tucker: WHY DOES ANY OF
THAT MEAN?
WE DON’T KNOW, JOE BIDEN DOESN’T
EITHER.
IT’S ALL GOOD, MAN.
THIS IS NOT A CANDIDATE WHO
COULD SOON BE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
DON’T TELL HIM THAT, IT WILL
ONLY MAKE HIM ANXIOUS.
THE PEOPLE AROUND BIDEN, IN
CONTRAST, ARE NOT ANXIOUS, THEY
ARE COMPLETELY IN CONTROL AND
YESTERDAY THEY GAVE THE REST OF
US A GLIMPSE OF WHAT THAT IS,
THE BIDEN CAMPAIGN RELEASED A
LONG DOCUMENT OUTLINING ITS
GOALS, WRITTEN BY ERIC HOLDER,
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ, AMONG
OTHERS.
THESE ARE THE PEOPLE WHO WILL
RUN THE COUNTRY IF JOE BIDEN IS
ELECTED IN NOVEMBER, SO WHAT’S
THEIR PLAN?
IN A SENTENCE, THEY’D LIKE TO
MAKE THE REST OF AMERICA VERY
MUCH LIKE OUR BIGGEST CITIES
HAVE BECOME.
SQUALID, DANGEROUS, CHAOTIC AND
UNHAPPY.
THEY’D LIKE TO DO TO YOUR
NEIGHBORHOOD WHAT THEY HAVE DONE
TO NEW YORK CITY.
THE MAIN THING THEY’VE DONE TO
NEW YORK IS MAKE IT SCARY.
VIOLENT CRIME IS SURGING
DRAMATICALLY THERE AS WE HAVE
TOLD YOU NIGHT AFTER NIGHT AND
ONE OF THE MAIN REASONS FOR THAT
IS THE ELIMINATION OF CASH BAIL,
THE CITY NO LONGER HOLDS OF THE
PEOPLE THAT ARRESTS, CRIMINALS
ARE IN AND OUT OF CUSTODY
IMMEDIATELY.
IT’STHE BIDEN CAMPAIGN PLANS TO
ABOLISH CASH BAIL EVERYWHERE.
NO BAIL FOR ANY CRIME
NATIONWIDE.
THINK ABOUT WHAT THAT WOULD
MEAN.
AMERICANS ARE FLEEING URBAN
AREAS IN HUGE NUMBERS.
BIG CITIES ARE TO MISMANAGE,
THEY’RE TOO DANGEROUS.
UNLESS YOU ARE VERY RICH ARE
VERY POOR, YOU’RE GETTING OUT.
NEW YORK CITY LOST 53,000 PEOPLE
IN 2019, THEY WILL LOSE MORE FAR
MORE THAN THAT THIS YEAR.
MOST OF THESE REFUGEES HAVE
RELOCATED TO THE SUBURBS.
THEY ARE NOT.
DEMOCRATS WANT TO ABOLISH THE
SUBURBS, THEY ARE TO CLEAN AND
NICE AND THEREFORE BY DEFINITION
THEY ARE RACIST.
THE BIDEN CAMPAIGN HAS HIGHLY
SPECIFIC PLANS ON HOW TO DO
THIS.
IT’S CALLED AFFIRMATIVELY
FURTHERING FAIR HOUSING, THE HUD
REGULATION WRITTEN DURING THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION.
BIDEN’S ADVISORS CLAIM TO
ENFORCE IT, WILL CUT OFF
CRITICAL FEDERAL FUNDS FOR
MUNICIPALITIES UNLESS THEY
SUBMIT TO FEDERAL CONTROL OF
URBAN PLANNING.
TOWNS WILL BE ORDERED TO ABOLISH
ZONING FOR SINGLE-FAMILY HOUSING
BECAUSE SINGLE-FAMILY HOMES,
NEEDLESS TO SAY, ARE RACIST.
LOW INCOME FEDERALLY SUBSIDIZED
APARTMENTS WILL GO UP IN THE
SUBURBS.
IT’S A GOOD BET YOU WON’T SEE
ANY OF THIS, YOU WON’T C
PROJECTS BUILT IN ASPEN OR
MARTHA’S VINEYARD OR ANYWHERE
ELSE ERIC HOLDER VACATIONS BUT
IN YOUR NEIGHBORHOOD?
YOUR KIDS SCHOOLS WILL CHANGE,
THE BIDEN CAMPAIGN HAS VOWED TO
BRING BACK TITLE IX RULES,
COLLEGES WILL ONCE AGAIN IGNORED
DUE PROCESS AND THE PRESUMPTION
OF INNOCENCE AND INSTEAD USE
KANGAROO COURTS TO ASSESS
SEXUAL ASSAULT ALLEGATIONS ON
CAMPUS.
THE COUNTRY’S K-12 SCHOOLS
EFFECTIVELY WILL ABANDON
CLASSROOM DISCIPLINE, SCHOOLS
WILL SUSPEND STUDENTS BASED ON
THEIR BEHAVIOR RATHER THAN
ACCORDING TO A STRICT RACIAL
QUOTA SYSTEM AND WILL BE
PUNISHED FOR THAT.
YOU WILL HAVE NO CHOICE BUT TO
KEEP YOUR KIDS ENROLLED ANYWAY
BECAUSE BIDEN’S CAMPAIGN PLEDGE
IS TO ABOLISH ALL PROGRAMS THAT
PROVIDE PARENTS VOUCHERS OR TAX
BREAKS TO SEND THEIR KIDS
SOMEWHERE ELSE AND THEN THE
BIDEN PLAN GETS REALLY AMBITIOUS
AMBITIOUS.
IT WOULD USE THE FEDERAL RESERVE
TO FIX THE "RACIAL WAGE GAP."
CENTRAL BANKERS WILL BE
ENCOURAGED TO DECIDE IF YOU ARE
BEING PAID TOO MUCH BASED ON
YOUR SKIN COLOR.
SOUNDS LIKE A GREAT WAY TO UNITE
THE COUNTRY.
ONE THING THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION WON’T ENFORCE IS
IMMIGRATION LAW, THE PLAN
PROMISES TO END WORKPLACE
EMIGRATION RATES, THAT WOULD
MEAN CORPORATIONS COULD BRING IN
A EFFECTIVELY UNLIMITED AMOUNTS
OF LOW-WAGE ILLEGAL FOREIGN
LABOR, GOOD LUCK FINDING YOUR
SON A JOB ONCE HE’S BOUNCED OUT
OF COLLEGE BY THOSE KANGAROO
COURTS.
YOU MAY THINK THIS ALL SOUNDS
TOO CRAZY TO BE REAL.
POLITICIANS MAKE A LOT OF
PROMISES RIGHT BEFORE ELECTIONS
AND BIDEN WOULD NEVER ACTUALLY
DO ANY OF THIS BECAUSE DEMOCRATS
WOULD BE WORRIED ABOUT LOSING
THE NEXT ELECTION IF THEY DID.
THESE ARE NOT POPULAR PROGRAMS
BUT THE BIDEN PEOPLE HAVE
THOUGHT THIS THROUGH AND THEIR
PLAN ANSWERS THAT QUESTION AND
SOLVES THE PROBLEM.
IT INCLUDES CITIZENSHIP AND
VOTING RIGHTS FOR ALL ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS CURRENTLY LIVING IN
THIS COUNTRY.
THAT’S AT LEAST 22 MILLION
PEOPLE, THAT MEANS 22 MILLION
BRAND-NEW VOTERS SPREAD OUT
ACROSS 50 STATES.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF THEM WILL
FAITHFULLY VOTE FOR THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
BY THE WAY, THAT’S NOT EVEN
INCLUDING ALL THE NEW ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION WE WILL DOUBTLESS
GET WITH NEW BORDER CONTROLS,
BIDEN CAMPAIGN ALSO PROMISES A
MORATORIUM ON DEPORTATION.
SO THERE IT IS, THAT’S THE BIDEN
PLAN.
IT’S NOT REALLY A BLUEPRINT TO
GOVERN THE COUNTRY, IT IS A
PROMISE TO UTTERLY REMAKE THE